Over the last decade and a half, we’ve moved
from describing cancer as it appears under
the microscope to a molecular diagnosis of
a cancer that’s based on the changes in
the genome.
Next generation sequencing technologies have
allowed us to discover those genetic abnormalities
at a dizzying rate, generating terabytes and
petabytes of data that overwhelm the ability
of most cancer researchers to wrangle and
understand.
There’s just too much data, it’s in too
many places, and it’s too diverse.
With the genomic data commons it will be much
easier to get the data and to analyze it at
the scale they need.
One of the really important parts of the genomic
data commons is having the ability for every
time a data submission happens, to analyze
it in exactly the same way and harmonize those
data with all the other data that's been submitted
to the genomic data commons.
There's no other resource out there like it.
We can compare our data from our patients,
to data that came in through The Cancer Genome
Atlas studies, from many other studies.
We will be able to do a lot of analysis without
having to download a lot of data.
We’ll be able to analyze it online.
The GDC is an essential tool if we are going
to understand the data we collect, get the
information we need out of it, to improve
the way we treat cancer.
The GDC provides an exciting new opportunity
for cancer researchers.
They will be able to upload their own data
to the GDC and therefore use all the bioinformatics
tools that are present in the GDC to understand
their own data.
But also, to see how it relates to all of
the other data.
Over time this will also increase the size
and the number of cases that are present in
the GDC, giving us greater statistical power.
We can start to do a much better job of tailoring
specific therapies, specific treatments for
a patient based on the experience we see with
other patients.
You can’t overestimate the power of this
tool to help us us understand how to manage
our patients, what drugs to give them, and
as this grows, whether they are going to respond
to these drugs or not.
This is going to help us all.
The genomic information is really life or
death to our patients, it makes such a big
difference.